c'est un atelier de travail pas comme
les autres cet atelier chant de été
conçu pour répondre aux besoins de
personnes déficientes intellectuelles
avec un trouble envahissant du
développement mais qui présente aussi
des troubles graves de comportement
leurs besoins sont tellement grand qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres endroits même dans
les milieux comme notament ne pourrait
pas les accueillir donc à ce moment là
soit qu'ils restent dans leur famille et
ça devient très lourdes pour leur
famille parce que nous ils viennent ici
le jour où soit ils restent dans leurs
ressources
c'est de mettre en place des
aménagements qui vont faire en sorte que
ben ils vont être quand même y voit une
bien
puis on n'entend pas de bruit pour
tailler des usagers que des troubles de
comportement qui viennent d'arriver
avec l'aide des intervenantes nadia
arrive à maintenir sa cadence de travail
trier les étiquettes destinés à des
emballages de fromage en étant entouré
de choses qu'il a calmé la rassure je
n'attache ce problème
avant la rénovation ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'atelier la
clientèle était moins lourde si on peut
dire ainsi puis c'était vraiment un
atelier comme une usine une chat mais ça
répondait plus du tout il y avait trop
de bruit il y avait trop timide et puis
nos usages et ben se désorganiser
faisait des crises cet apport amman et
ça devenait plus sécuritaire pour eux ni
pour nos employés
je sais que je dérange
et ce à l'apaisement les utilisent
sommes toujours en prévention donc c'est
à l'horaire de l'usagé autrefois on
avait tous les jours on avait un ou deux
âgées kitty
crise puis maintenant il y en a plus
les matériaux les tam peuvent résister à
presque 100 les faits qui peuvent pas
être détruite
les immenses ballons qui traînent dans
les couloirs sont là pour servir de zone
tampon aux besoins tout est pensé pour
préserver le calme et prévenir
l'agitation il ya même des petits grad a
tant réussi fait que si l'usagé moment
donné a besoin qu'on réduise les stimuli
ou même nous on juge qui aurait besoin
de ça pèse un peu plus bas on va
utiliser le gradateur participe de fait
le champion des cubicules individuel pas
de couleurs vives et on favorise les
pictogrammes adaptés aux besoins des
personnes autistes
qu'est ce que tu fabriques du skate 2
contre travail de la veine des broches
de jusqu'à 2 caps chant et vis plus tout
ça les travaux ont été long mais depuis
l'ouverture de l'atelier rénové en
janvier c'est le jour et la nuit il y à
l'aménagement des lieux bien sûr mais
aussi les employés leur nombre leur rôle
et leur expertise
personnel c'est d'éducateurs spécialisés
un ratio d'à peu près 1 pour 3 des
agents d'intervention qui sont formés
puis des intervenants qui travaillent en
prévention parce que ce qu'on veut c'est
prévenir l'apparition de troubles de
comportement on veut pas des fiers à
bras ce ne sont pas des même si vous
allez vous allez voir on est bons
gabarits mais c'est des agents et au
même titre que nous ayons un jeu ils ont
un rôle à jouer dans l'intervention qui
leur rôle est important parce que c'est
aussi un rôle d'apaisement sont là pour
donner le high five pour encourager
le sus du centre sud de l'île de
montréal a choisi de faire ce qu'il faut
pour ne pas laisser tomber ces gens qui
demandent beaucoup d'encadrement
les usagers vont devenir ce qu'ils
voient dans mon regard piquant il me
regarde je veux qu'ils voient que je
crois parce qu'ils sont capables
d'accomplir parce qu'ils sont capables
de grandes choses avec les moyens qu'ils
ont
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal